personally I've tried therapy and the
first time I tried it I walked out in an
anger and rage and I was like human and
the second time I told her it's not
going to work I don't think you can fix
my problems
I've been to the therapist before and I
just thought therapy was like stupid for
the most part and now I'm in school for
psychology and I see the women that are
therapists and they're nuts I would not
go to therapy yeah I feel like they
don't care they're just getting paid to
do what they need to do they don't give
a so yeah yeah but but I do think
there are some male therapists that are
helpful mostly like male
um what do you think about that
um I've never had a male therapist and I
wouldn't go to a male therapist because
I need to I need to connect with a woman
that's like you know what I mean like
women's
no that's broken like me not necessarily
but I feel like women connect easier no
I think I think women look to comfort
and men look to solve problems and
that's why I don't think therapy works
when they're women most of the time
there's exceptions because like men like
women are just gonna comfort you they're
going to tell you what you want to hear
where men will tell you how to fix it
but the problem is like women we never
want to fix it like actually fix it
that's interesting yeah it's true I had
a male therapist actually before I had a
therapist for eight years I'm not in
therapy anymore but the first four years
was it was a woman in the last four
years of man and I'm not in therapy
anymore and I'm like I'm good now but
that's because it was a man not a woman
because when I was a woman they would
just sit there and soak in all my issues
and all the problems and there was never
a solve or a solution no one was trying
to help me and then trauma what's her
like and they call everything trauma
everything you know everything's abuse
or trauma I'm like what the what do
you mean I don't believe in trauma I
don't believe in trauma either it's a
bunch of this it's just so that
psychologists can make money off yeah
well I do I do believe in like War
trauma like from War what do you mean
like I think if a guy goes to war and
sees some like sees things that's real
trauma but the way we use it today my
ex-boyfriend cheated on me my issues
everything's true everything but can I
say something don't you think there's
something called unhealed baggage that
we'd be carrying with us because we
haven't overcome how we felt in the last
relationship you should just get over it
okay
yeah yeah I think that we should quit
whining our great grandmothers had to
deal with it like they used to have
plagues and getting cheated on like
this is just the example I'm using but
most of modern day problems are really
nothing compared to like 100 200 years
ago you could get the plague and like
die you know that'd be traumatic being
afraid you know and you're right you
know what because I feel like personally
I've been through so much I haven't had
real therapy and I'm I'm strong I'm
still going you know I mean it's not
affecting me maybe it is in a way but
it's not in intervening in my life yeah
strong strongly the reveling in the
story is what a lot of the women
therapists were using Penelope is my
daughter and they were um you know
really listening to your story and and
giving a lot of emphasis to it like you
were really overweight and the
therapists were like no no don't talk
about it don't don't try to help her
lose weight and I'm like what do you
mean like we've got to fix this problem
like what's the plan it's so frustrating
oh so they wouldn't try to solve like
how big were you I was 300 pounds shut
up I was 300 pounds you look great
foreign
how did your life change from going from
300 pounds to I don't know what you are
now but clearly not so I lost 130 pounds
actually wow and you're tall too yes
what are you six two no five nine and a
half oh you you look tall as heck
okay
um but basically I was you know I think
part of the problem was because I was in
therapy for so long and I nobody told me
in therapy that there was anything wrong
with me and I had depression I had
anxiety I had suicidal thoughts and I
was not I didn't have a good
relationship with my father at the time
and nobody was saying oh you need to
lose the weight your life will be better
if you just do that nobody they tried to
give me medication they tried to give me
pills they tried to put me in more
therapy and it was until one day I
looked in there and I'm like I don't
want to be like this anymore I don't
want to feel like this anymore and to be
honest the body positivity movement
crushed my soul and told me oh you
should be you know you're beautiful no
matter what size you are you're
beautiful no matter you know how much
you weigh you're beautiful no matter
what you eat you can eat anything you
want and you're gorgeous go girl and I
thought it was okay wow I thought it was
okay because no one said anything and I
could be sitting here if 300 pounds
right now if I didn't make the decision
to say Penelope you need to get your
butt off the couch and work out fix your
diet fix your mental health fix
everything and now I'm perfectly fine no
meds just naturally all natural what do
you do you think that contributes to 70
of women being overweight in the U.S
completely I completely think that
yeah go ahead no I just think that I
think that the fact that people are
obese and that they make all these
excuses for oh I'm obvious because of
the summer because you can lose weight
no matter what anyone can lose weight
it's just about finding the right way to
do it and what do you think of the women
that say we need like representation and
magazines
um we need fat chicks on the cover
Victoria's Secret fashion show it
proposes me so it repulses me to see
that because you've been there it does
because I've been there and not only
that but you are showing thousands and
millions of women in the world that it
is one okay to be unhealthy too okay to
be slowly killing yourself and three
okay to go outside and dress
provocatively with your rolls out
I was a plus-sized model right in the
90s you were a plus-sized mom in the 90s
yeah is there anything wrong with a
little plus-sized girl yeah because what
about the people that actually what
about the people that actually can't
lose weight
but what about people that actually but
they mentally can't say that for the
rest of their life they're going to be
that same size they need some they need
some empowerment because otherwise they
could you know
do you go to um uh basketball game and
look to see like an NBA game all right
what do you guys have since football
right football here you go to a football
game here and you try to see average
football players
average like below average football
players play football here when you go
to a professional game do we see them no
do you do you go there to see that oh uh
well no so then why on the cover of
magazines which is supposed to be the
epitome of beauty do we have below
average women on it right
like why like why is that why do we need
that
I I feel ashamed and I don't like it I
don't want to see it I think you're
right about the fact that they're doing
it too because you know if you want to
talk about the health system and the way
the world's set up they don't want
people to come out of a BCE right so
they're going to make it look like it's
okay they don't want you to so so why
wouldn't we have healthy people on the
Mac front of Mag I'm not saying like
because they didn't want that yeah yeah
but you said we need that earlier no but
I was saying that for the people that
don't that actually I think in my head
I'm thinking for the people that
actually because a person that actually
cannot overcome obesity and for the rest
of their life till the age of 60 70
they're still going to be overweight
those people are probably feeling yes
like they're they're feeling okay
they're empowered
would you rather be in power than commit
suicide because people think oh look at
you but when you're when you're
overeating you're slowly committing
suicide exactly my mother did it wow she
died wow like 500 calls of death was
severe obesity and then when my daughter
started getting the weight I was
freaking out right and so that's why
we're on a mission and yeah but don't
you think there's a certain level though
obviously there's obesity and there's
because I feel like the modeling world
has always
promoted unhealthy unhealthiness and
that makes sense even the slim women
slimming women was like six and like
very small do you know what I'm saying
that would it looked like they weren't
eating outside
Marilyn Mon
K was very slim and they wouldn't eat or
they wouldn't do something just to fit
in a certain calories you know what I'm
saying I mean there are some but I just
maybe for like for like an early 2000s
we look at the last like 100
women on the covers were just beautiful
what's the average weight you would say
uh let's see I don't know off the top of
my head as a Ford Model the the girls
who are in straight size modeling they
were size four and that's because the
samples are made in a size four
and so it's all four different from uk4
it is a bit Yeah like more like a two I
think it'd be more like a two in there
the average the average woman she's gone
okay the average woman is 5'4 I'm in
America and I can do UK in a second five
four twenty years old and weighs 170
pounds oh what's that in stone please
[Music]
average Stones I don't actually know
indeed but that's overweight I would say
that that average that she just quoted
would be a 12 stone 12 12 12.14 okay
because I would think that average is
between 8 to 12. I think if you're in a
good in shape 12 there's good In-Shape
12 women
and you think about that then we're
talking obesity you know what I'm saying
um it's BMI yeah to be honest sorry uh
to be honest it depends I think like
around 10 years ago it used to be way
different I think now they kind of
raised it you know yeah yeah I think 10
years ago I went I don't know I was like
65 kilos I don't know what that is sorry
and and Stones it must be like 165 in
um in America 2.2 to one yeah and they
would already say oh you should try to
lose weight you know for your height
whatever now if you look at that they're
like yeah you're perfect you can be a
model so it really changed in the last
decade I would say really it did so it
was about around 10 years ago was there
plus size models is that a new thing
I'll be honest really we're definitely
we're on America's Next Top Model I mean
it wasn't that as common though but I
definitely I I used to watch Tyra Banks
anyone yeah yeah anyone
yeah but they weren't like this they
weren't like the the like yeah yeah like
you see today they were just kind of
like they're like tens big boned
all right yeah ten is not big no Ten's
not big
industry but this one I'm saying for the
modeling yeah but again it's like when
you go to an NBA game I want to see good
basketball players like it's supposed to
be the epitome of beauty yeah like now
we're rewarding average like I don't
want to see average chicks like faces on
the cover I don't want to see average
bodies if she's a if she's a good I'm
not saying plus plus but she's a good
size 12 with good Curves in that Amanda
want to see that we don't really want to
just see slim girls all the time I'll be
honest I believe that I believe that
some men like that I really do it's
typical to be honest it's typically
broke man because if you look at
original yeah yeah if you look at like
half like I'm just I
there's no fence but no no it's like
like when you like when you rich man
what do they have on their arms
but the only reason why they have slim
women is because the slim women are in
the higher echelons of places where the
other women no not in no let's not talk
about beauty only I'm talking about
venues certain venues certain places
that they get to go to certain women
can't get to go there okay Leonardo
Caprio if he wanted a big chick he
couldn't find one no he couldn't find
one but I'm saying in certain the plate
the venue the events no events from
Instagram come on
they could get any chicken yeah they can
but but do you think Leonardo this guy
named bear girls DMS just hollering
girls in the DMs
I think he'll I think he'll pick like he
that he won chick uh the Hadid
the model yeah I don't know what I say
it's like if you look at the richest
most successful man they they typically
have slim women I'm saying if you're
looking at the richest parts of events
and venues you've made fair whatever and
in America Manhattan whatever if you go
to the upper echelons or places you know
what I'm saying do you really think that
the only reason they're with slim
beautiful women is because of the events
they go to no but I'm saying because of
the environment that they're in okay
that was because that would that is
society's ideal of a beautiful woman
that's why and so I feel like the plus
model came in when people started
complaining that there wasn't a
selection of varieties why is it that
all around the world they like young
beautiful slim women everywhere even in
different societies with completely
different cultures please
please do not bring out this one
fringent tribe in Africa everyone brings
up but it's like they're it's such a
small percentage of the world well
Africa there's something Africa they
bring up some tribe in Africa that likes
the fat women but it's a very very I've
done this conversation well if you think
ahead but if you think about is the
motherland
continuous
me coming no you know deep down you know
that men like slim women in jail I'm
gonna be honest I don't think they do
I'm gonna be honest and I'm gonna say
this coming from
being a black man okay if I'm talking
about being a black man or from a black
perspective of I feel like majority of
us men like thicker women okay well and
and even me Jordan
but you keep talking about celebrity men
that are going to be around to hire
women that are that certain women I'm
from a one person not a family my dad my
dad my dad is a top one percent earner I
grew up around in a wealthy neighborhood
I'm telling you they do not put fat
chicks on their arms in high class in
high class society and celebrities want
people with the option to not have a fat
chick on their arm do not all right well
even like what's having a conversation
the other day with with a woman and she
was a slim woman she's from America as
well so American
um I think Atlanta or whatever and she
said when she was slim she was only
getting approached by white men okay she
put she put on a lot of weight no not a
lot of weight but these tips got body
whatever blah blah now she's getting
approached by a lot of black men which
is what do you get on what I'm saying if
you if you look at it on on the Democrat
thing which which successful black men
that we know are dating well we're only
going to talk about successful yeah
because those are the men with options
broke men don't have as many options as
rich men definitely have options they do
not have as many options as Richmond so
if you look at the men with the most
options to look okay so if we want to
see what women want we got to look at
the women with the most options who do
the most beautiful the youngest most
fertile women pick if you want to look
at men what do men like we have to look
at the men with the most options because
it's not really fair to say oh I like
fat chicks if I make you know ten
dollars an hour at Taco Bell right like
you can't you don't guess
yeah no I I get that but obviously if
you're going if you're talking about
celebrity celebrities are guided but I
didn't just say celebrities I'm from I'm
my dad is in like he's a top one percent
earner I grew up with 10 siblings in a
10 bedroom mansion in a community where
many people made that amount of money
yeah so so I've been around a successful
wealthy man and they don't put fat
chicks sometimes they they do get fat
later but they don't appreciate that you
know what I mean so yeah but I hear what
you're saying what I'm saying the reason
these men obviously gonna go for similar
because they're around that's what you
being in the top one percent and being
in in this neighborhood okay it allows
you to see different things together
no if you do have obviously if you do
have money a lot of people with money
are in the gym they do it because they
have more time on their hands to do
other things you get what I'm saying no
they have less time it's a guaranteed
you think they'll have less time people
absolutely have less time totally no I
don't know yeah you know no no I could
tell you 100 but also I think the reason
that a lot of woman and are Slimmer and
why do you think more successful men
want women who are Slimmer it's because
it's healthier for them like their risk
for getting you know diseases at an
older age their risk for having
pregnancy risks are much lower if
they're not overweight yeah so why would
a man choose a woman if he wants to
marry them if they're going to die at 50
if they're going to die at 70 if they're
going to have their children's gonna
have to be at risk for birth risk I mean
I would never want that and I don't
think I don't think men want that like
when men are looking for wives they're
not looking for like women who are going
to have risks and we even saw how for
you how your bad habit passed on to her
and that's like if you have a bad habit
yourself you will pass it on to your
kids and then it's another problem that
your kid like because I had the same my
mom used to feed me like Pop-Tarts and
stuff when I was a kid and I and my mom
was pretty big and then she ended up
like losing all the weight
um and she told me like she literally
did it for my dad
um and
um yeah I have a sugar addiction to this
day you know what I mean so it's like
bad habits pass from like the parents to
the kids exactly and sugar is more
addictive than cocaine yeah crazy yeah I
do miss Pop-Tarts they make healthy pop
darts but they're really not healthy
they're still junk food no I said I
don't like I like the cinnamon one
I wanted the complete opposite direction
like total Neurosis I got my bachelor's
master's degree in nutrition I helped
thousands of people lose weight regain
their health and it was almost like her
Rebellion so her choice to gain autonomy
through overeating and ill health was
almost you know well it was just so so
crazy for me because I was so happy I
thought you said you were overweight as
a kid I was but as an adult what were
you doing my whole life until I was like
15 I was like rebelling against her I
was like I'm gonna eat all the junk food
so I'd go to my friend's house and stuff
my face with pizza and then their moms
would call her and be like oh my gosh is
your daughter okay she's eating like a
box of pizza and like my whole box of
goldfish wow and I would just do that
and then I come home and I would never
like her cooking even though she's the
best cook I know but like I would I just
rebelled my whole life yeah it was
terrible as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible